emmanuel macron aime les symboles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'hymne européen le soir de son élection
la pyramide du louvre une flamme ravivée
dans un ossuaire où se mêlent soldats
allemands et français
c'est le premier lieu de réconciliation
et cette fin de semaine une cérémonie
dans la clairière où était signé
l'armistice de la grande guerre il ya
cent ans
mais le président a l'intention
d'honorer cet homme le maréchal philippe
pétain héros pendant la première guerre
collabos pendant la deuxième on peut
avoir être un gros soldats la première
guerre mondiale et avoir conduit à des
choix funeste durant la deuxième comme
la rafle du vélodrome d'hiver à paris
13000 juifs déportés vers les camps en
1942 au total sous la république de
vichy qu'il dirige
quelque 75 mille juifs français seront
envoyés à la mort tu ne fais aucun
raccourci mais je n'occulte aucune page
de l'histoire
mon rôle n'est pas de comprendre que ça
choque ou de commenter les gens mon rôle
est d'essayer d'expliquer portée des
convictions
le risque c'est que ce symbole soit plus
fort que sa conviction honorer un homme
qui a été frappé de l'indignité
nationale
c'est peut-être dénaturer cette cet
hommage que l'on veut rendent aux autres
le héros de la suze ne pardonne en rien
mais je ne veux en rien notre histoire
et il n'est pas le premier
la gloire qui la quitte à verdun ne
saurait être contestées cet homme c'est
philippe pétain
hélas l'actuel président veut maintenant
clore la polémique ici mathieu prost
radio canada
non